科学的に物事を考える人々も
やっぱり人間には自由がないと言ってるんですね
だからそれもあるそういう証拠があって言ってることで
だから真実わけでもないんです
なぜならば我々集中したりするとマヌスカーラ使っちゃうと違うものが見える
例えば本を開けたら本を一番見やすいところが見える
そこでじっと見たら見にくいところが見える
例えば本を見たら まあみんな見るというよりは頭で妄想し始めちゃいますからね
そうじゃなくて 客観的に字だけ見てみたらどうですか
読もうとしないで字だけ見ると
ちゃんと紙の上にインキがついていることは見えてくるんですね
普通だったらそう見えない
もう文章を読みつつ読んでしまってるんです
私の場合 すごい苦労するのは
このローマ字見ちゃったら
もうすぐもう字で見るんじゃなくて
もう全部読んで もうもう頭に入って
もう全部終わってるんです
開けた瞬間で だからすごいきついんです
全部変なもの 変な英語ばっかり見えちゃいますから
でも日本の方々は誰もそういう英語を見て全然違和感も気持ち悪くは感じない
その場合は字だけ見ているんだから
そこで変な日本語を見ても
私はそんなにきつく感じないんですね
先に字見てるんだから
書いた絵を それはマヌスカーラの差で
そこで我々も読める本でもじっと見ちゃうと
字の形やら崩れてるところやら
いろんなこと見えるかもしれません
そこは自分の意思で見ているんですね
ですから 自由か自由がないかっていう問題ではないんですよ
放っておけば自由じゃないし
コントロールすれば自分の意思の通りにコントロールできるし
そういうことで仏教は人は自由ですかと
自由じゃないんですかと
どっちでもなく因果法則ですよと
それは中道なんですよ
中道っていうのは真ん中ではなくて
そういう そういう法則だよと説明していること
そこで一応七つの心所の二回目の説明は終わります
まあマヌスカーラから飛びましたけど
まあ簡単にマヌスカーラっていうのはそういうことなんですね
次にこの 殺心所というところがあります
四十七ページの パキンナカチェータ・シクナ
このパキンナカ・チェータ・シクナはこの文字通りにちょっとややこしいんです
で 七つありまして まあ覚えておいた方が大変便利かもしれません
もう一つ ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラ・ヴィリヤ・ピーティ・チャンダ
これカタカナにするのはもう大変難しいんですね
いっぱいヴィーがありますよ
カタカナでヴィー書けませんから
ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラ・ヴィリヤ・ピーティ・チャンダ
とにかくカタカナでは書けない字がいっぱい出ます
パーリ語で もうティーがあっても書けないし
そこはカタカナ作った人が悪いんです
イーがあるならばなんでね
パーがあるならば なんでティーがないんですか
ティーの代わりにチー入れて
それでパーリ語でシという言葉はよく必要なんですよ SI
のシ これもカタカナでない
サーがあるんだけど 次ないのはシーなんですね
それはまあ余計な話で
で この六つはあの あ リソース抜けてますね
どっちが来ます？アディモクは
失礼しました ヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラ・アディモク・ヴィジェーティーティ・チャンダ
で あの ちょっとまずは説明してみましょう
で 説明はこのアビダンマの注釈書の注釈書がありまして
ずいぶん長い長い時間がもう枚数使って説明していますが
それでも説明はしっかりしてないんです
こういうテキストと違って
私は今考えているのは
このアビダンマの 本当のアビダンマのテキストの注釈書なんです
それはもうブッダゴーサ長老が書いたアッタサーリニというテキストで
もう随分もう延々と説明するんです
それを全部丁寧に読んで終わったところで何もわからないと
何言ってるんですか？ですからわからないかもしれません
でもこの場合もちょっと工夫はあります
理解する 一般日常の世界の我々の心の働きから理解すれば理解できると思います
そこでヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラって 2つまとめてみると
一般的に言えばこの考えることなんです
頭で 頭の中で 一般的に言えばヴィタッカで
それかそれから順番で説明に行きましょう
そこでヴィタッカ・ヴィチャーラというのは考えてること
まあ瞑想で言えば いくら瞑想したっても頭の中でも考えている
その状態 例えばふくらみを見ている時でも
やっぱりそれでも頭が活動している
状態を vitakka vicāra状態なんですね
そこで vitakka と vicāra の次に別々にします vitakka
だけ取ったらこの論理という意味なんですね Argument
論理という意味なんです
じゃあちょっとものを見ただけで聞いただけで
我々はそんなにも頭の中で論理的に何かしますか？と言えば
そんなことはしませんね
そんなことしません だからそれは論理でもなく
ちょっと似ている働き
それで次にアビダンマの説明に行きます
この 普通我々は何か理解しようと思っちゃうと
何か論理的な構造を作っちゃうでしょ
何でも人間というのは理解しちゃう
知ったり見たり聞いたりすると
何かその中で何か論理構造があるんですね
あまり気にしないんだけどね
例えば自分の家の中でいろんなところで物を置いておくと
その物を置いておく時でも
頭の中で何か論理構造が働いているんです
そこでまた置いたところからそのものを取り出した時も
ちゃんとその論理に沿って
あれはあっちありますよ
あれは 3番目の引き出しの左側にありますよと
右側にありますよと 後ろにありますよと言えるでしょう
じゃあ例えば自分がタオルを畳んで置いておいたと
じゃあタオルをどこに置きました？と聞くと
ちゃんと説明できるんですね
こういうところにあります
お手洗いはどこですか？と
こう行ってこう行ってここですよと説明できるんですよ
そういうわずかなところの中でも
なんか私たちの頭の中で何かシステムがあるでしょ
いつでも たとえわずかでも
そういうシステムないと
我々は全部きれいにさっぱり忘れちゃうんです
タオルを畳んで置いたんだけど
もうどこに置いたかもう忘れちゃったと
その忘れる時はよくわかるでしょ
なぜ忘れたかというと
なぜ置いたかという論理が忘れちゃった
なかったんだからなんですね
例えば必死で人と喋っていて
そこで自分が何か物を持ってどこかに入れておく
それから探すは探すが見つからない
その時はただ入れたことは入れたんだけど
人の話に夢中になっちゃって見つからないだけで
そうじゃなくて入れますということで入れたところで
もうちゃんとそこで論理構造ができているんですね
ですから 論理というと
まあ論理と言うんですか
日本語で まあちょっとした
ちょっとしたロジカル構成なんですね
で そんな論理という大げさなことじゃないんだけど
やっぱりそれ大げさにすれば論理なんですよ
で つまらないことでも聞いてみましょう
なんでスプーンはここに置いておきますか？と
どんな家庭の奥さんでも聞いてみましょう
ちゃんと説明してくれます
ということは そこに論理構造が本人考えてなかったんだけど
質問すると出るんだから
ですから 我々のどんな行動の中にも
ある基本的な論理構造があるんです
それ育てればみんなすごい合理的
論理的なので それは全く無視して妄想だけ回転させてるんだから
人類はみんな非合理的なんですよ
ですから この我々育てるところで
一番基本的な単純なところで
そこで生命の働きが基本だからね
そこをちゃんと見ると
そこでちゃんと論理的なシステムがあるんです
それを育ててほしい 妄想ではなくて
例えば朝起きて歯を磨くと
歯を磨くと人はバラバラですけど
歯ブラシはどうやって置きますか？と
家の中に 3人いるならば
もう置き方はみんな同じじゃないんですね
そこでわかるのは これバラバラではないかと思うかもしれません
でもその置いた人から聞いてみれば
なんであなたはこの毛の方がこう置いたんですかと
例えば一人がこう左側に毛の方がもう次に歯磨き人は毛の方を右側にあるように置いとくかもしれませんでしょ
そうするといい加減バラバラではなくと思うかもしれない
そうじゃないんです その本人に聞けば
ここにその本人に聞き捨ててないだけで
そこに論理システムが出ているんです
例えば右手に何かありましたと
そこで歯ブラシをそのまま簡単に置きますということで
簡単に置いたところで磨く部分が左側になったと
もう一人では何も持たないで洗って置いといた場合は右手で置いたんだから
ちゃんと右側に行ったと
これ何かそこにあるんです
すでに そこを我々は頭で考えて
これは無茶苦茶だからといって
ちゃんとした歯ブラシを置く
させておく 何か置き物を入れておくと
そこでみんな刺すかもしれませんだけどね
その時もその人の性格によって変わるんですよ
ですから わずかなことにしたっても
人間が何かそこでシステムがあるんです
それもやめられないんです
そこをその働き ヴィパッサナーなんです
この論理というのも全く同じことをちゃんと組織化して出来上がっちゃえば論理なんですよ
日常 毎日使っていること
そこでなぜサティを実践すると物忘れが消えるかと
というのは そこにその答えがあるんです
歯ブラシを置きますと
置くと その瞬間で そのなぜ
どのように なぜこのように置くかという
このヴィパッサナーに気づくのです
ですから忘れない で 自動販売機で時使って現車になると使ってすぐどこかに入れておくと
それで忘れちゃう 後で一生懸命探しちゃう
それはなぜ忘れたかというと
その時はまあ他のことに着替えて他のことを考えたりしている
こちらの論理コースは弱い
とにかくその時は入れればいいということだけなんですね
後で探して見つからないと
私も一回損しましたけど
この中に シルム そこでポケット一つあったんですね
そこであんたあの電車の中で切符を買って
それはちゃんと畳んでポケットに入れると
入れたら大丈夫だと思って入れたんですね
で すぐそこでそれ以上論理が行かなかったんです
でも問題はこの衣いろいろありますけど
同じものでしょ？着ているのは一枚なんですけど
そこで下に着ているものも同じ種類で
本当にポケットの中に入ったかとは確かめなかったんです
ポケットに入れたんだ
で 降りて探すは探すはなし
でも確かにポケットに入れたんだからって
ポケット全部見て全然ない
あれなんかボケちゃってカバンに入れたかなと思って
カバンはカバンに入れてなかったと
カバンの中身全部取り出してみたって
もうないことはない そこでやっぱり入れたっていうとこだけで
ちゃんと中に入ったかということは確かめなかったんだから
まあ単なる中に入っちゃって立ち上がっちゃったら
それはそのまま落ちると
ことでまた買わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃった
そういうことで そこで他の人はあんたまあもうまあああだこうだと言うかもしれませんでしょ
例えば僕にもう一人が人がいたならば
何か言われるかもしれませんけど
でもその瞬間で でも僕にはその時でも論理があったんです
非合理的でいい加減に入れたわけではないんです
一応ポケットに入れちゃえば取り出しやすいし
もう落ちないということで
じゃあポケットここにありますから
こうやって入れると でもそこはポケットの中ではなかったんですね
ですから こういう基本的な働きでは
ちゃんと論理は働いて
それはまあ結構失敗はしますけど
そのそこら辺ちょっと気を付ければ失敗はないんですね
人生は ですから 我々ものを覚えている時でも
いつでも頭の中で何とかのシステムができている
思い出す時にも そのシステムを通って思い出したりする
だいたい皆様はメモを書くのは上手で
いろんな図で物語として
いろんな何て言いますか
ダイアグラムいろいろ書いて説明するのは上手なんです
ということは 頭の中はまあそういう何でも形でできているとか
私の場合は頭の中でまるっきり何の形もない
ですから まあいろいろ線引いたり
丸描いたり もう三角描いたり考えたりするわけしない
形で考えません で だからといって
私にもちゃんとした論理構造はあるんです
ちゃんと物事を考えることもできるし
思い出すこともできる
頭の中でそうこうもまた
あまり素っ裸で入ってるわけでもないんです
だからそもそも 人によって動物でも同じことで
ちょっとしたそういう働きがあるんです
その働きにヴィタッカというんです
だからまあ簡単単純な日本語で何言うかやっぱりわからない
そんなその機能には すごい基本的な働きなんです
たとえ朝顔を洗ってタオルで顔を拭いて
例えば洗濯物カゴあったならば
このままポイと捨てたならば
大体男の人ってそういう性格でしょうに
で 奥さんに怒られるかもしれませんし
まあだらしないと でもそれは他の論理で見てだらしないというだけで
その瞬間 その人はある論理構造でそれやってるんです
それだと早くやればいいとかね
だから何が早いかというと
さっさと見てそれは早いんです
例えばシャツとか何とか脱いで
そのまま脱いだところでポイと
それで家を制する奥さんに対してはものすごいだらしないんだとかね
思っちゃいますけど 本人にはだらしないではなくて
違う論理構造を使ってる
簡単速くて便利とかね
[笑い]だからそういうことで
人間の性格の差によって
論理コースは当然そのその各自違うんですね
だから我々 その人の生き方が違う
そういうところで私もたまに言いますけどね
ちょっとわずかな心の動き
本人使っているものとかね
ちょっと見ただけで 僕らは性格はざっと読み取れる
その性格っていうのは
そういう基本的な生命としての一番大事な基本的な基準なんだ
そこはもう知ってるんです
何を勉強して 誰と喧嘩してるんですか？とか
そんなことは関係ない
僕らにとっては 奥さんと喧嘩したんですかと
別れてるんです 別居してる
それは性格に関係ないものなんです
カバン見ても本見ても
たとえこのアビダルマテキストにしたっても
その最初は印刷屋さん作ったものだから全く同じでしたけど
皆様自分の手で取って
これ私のテキストだよと言った瞬間から
もうそのテキストは違うんです
それで性格は見えるんです
そこはヴィパッサナーという働きには大変関係あるんです
だからヴィパッサナーは何と言えばいいんでしょうかね
一般日本語で言えばどちらの言葉は人生
あのブッダコース大長老の説明も
これほど私の説明ほど明確じゃないんです
できれば読んでみてください
すごい伝統的な説明はあることはありますけどね
そこで私たちは物を見たり
聞いたり 感じたり 味わったり
考えたりするときも その人というものは働くんですね
いつでもなぜ聞いたかと
例えば私は喋ってて 外で車の時効の音が入ったとすると
車の時効の音を聞くでしょう
そうすると人間のこのどうでもいい理屈で言えばそれはいけないことであって
今授業中だから授業を聞くのは正しいではないかと
なんでいけないことをしているんですかとか
いろんなもう道徳やらああだこうだいろんなくだらないこといっぱい出てきた
でも授業の話 音を聞かないで
自己の音を聞いた人には
心には別に間違っていることをやったわけじゃないんです
そこにちゃんとした論理構造が出てくるんです
で なんで我々は子供たちにいろんなことを言ったり
奥様たちが旦那さんにいろんなこと言ったって
なかなか性格変わらないでしょ
いくらいちいちうるさく言ったって
言わない方がいいんです
安全です 変わるわけじゃないんです
なぜならば 本人が別に変なことをやっているわけじゃないんです
これは変だと 違うとやってはいけないという論理だったらやらないんですね
そういうことでも わずかなことにしたっても
このジンという働きがあると理解しておきましょう
理解できるかどうか分かりませんんだけど
結局複雑なんです 次はヴィチャール
ヴィチャールは知ですか
ヴィチャール 知という漢字書いてますけどね
まあ漢字の意味は私はあまり全然わかりませんだけど
で ブッダ教長老の説明にも少々帯っていうと
このジンっていうのはすぐ出る論理で
ヴィチャールっていうのはもうちょっとそれについてもうほんのちょっと少し勘があるような感じなんですね
で こういう風に見ると両方理解できます
例えばお母さんがいて
子供がいて で 二人で歯を磨くと
そこでまず子供が歯を磨いて歯ブラシ置いて帰っちゃうと
次次のお母さんがいて
で 歯を磨くと 歯を磨いて歯ブラシを置いておくと
そこでお母さん 三番目の人がそれを見るとすぐわかるんですね
歯ブラシは違うことではなくて
これはお母さんが置いたもの
これは子供が置いたものとすぐわかるんです
同じものを置いてもらえばわかるでしょ
例えば歯ブラシはもう違いますから
わかり  同じガラスでも
まあ口を洗うようになったら
全く同じだったら 最初は子供は口を洗ってガラス置いて
次にお母さんがして自分のガラス全く同じ
それで口を洗って置いておく
そこで番目の人が見て見極めるでしょ？超能力なくても
このガラスは子供が使ったガラス
このガラスはお母さんが使ったガラス
そこでこのヴィチャールの方が
お母さんの方がもう働いているんです
子供の方がすごい弱い
ガラスを置いている方を見たら
まあもしかするとお母さんのはガラスを下に向いて置いておくかもしれませんし
子供はそのままかもしれませんし
でも番目の人は だからってそれはその関係ないんです
わからないんだから でもそこに何か差があるでしょ
で 一般常識で言えば お母さんというのは全部家の中の整理やらなんだかんだやってますから
何でもちゃんとしておかなくちゃいけないという責任感があって
自分の責任ということで
そこで自分がガラス置く場合はちゃんと正しく置いておくと
子供の場合はもう一応口を洗って洗えばいいぐらいで止まるんですね
口を洗えばいいと それ以上の世界はなし
で 口を洗ってガラスを置いたと
置くことさえ子供の世界には関係ないんです
口を洗ったらそれでいいんです
で 自動的に置くだけなんです
で そこで置く場合は 子供も論理は使ってますよ
置かなくちゃいけないんだから
別に手でずっと持っているわけにもいきませんし
落とすわけにもいきませんし
ですから置いておくと
で お母さんの場合はそうじゃないんですね
お母さんもガラスを置いておかなくちゃいけないということもありますけど
もうちょっとそこで意識が働くんです
そのもうちょっとはヴィチャールなんです
ジンとシの差はそういう差なんです
どういう他の説明は僕には何にもできないんです
[背景音楽]家の掃除頼んでみてみましょう
家のうちの旦那さんに
掃除機かけてくれた もうどうせ奥さんのこと怖いんだから言ったらまあやってくれるんでしょう
で それと奥さんが掃除かける
掃除機かけることだから
自動的に機械で埃を吸い取ることだから
結果は 100%同じはずなんですね
人間の論理で言えば でも 100%同じだと思いますか？全く違う
3番目の人が見たらすぐ言えるんです
この部屋は男が掃除した部屋で
この部屋は家の奥さんが掃除した部屋だとすぐわかる
僕だったらわかりますけど
だいたい人間誰でもわかると思いますよ
私に全く超能力ないんだから
私に持ってる能力はみんなにもみんな持ってると思ってます
そこは何 どんな差がありますかというと
旦那さんの場合は言われたんだからやると
自分の仕事でもなんでもないし
まあそれなりの合理的にちゃんと掃除機をすると
奥さんの場合はもうちょっとその辺でもっと詳しいというか
責任感があるというか
まあなんとか分かりませんだけど
もうちょっと違う形で違う感じでやる
もしかすると男が掃除機したところで
ものすごい厳密にホコリを全部綺麗にしたかもしれませんよ
奥さんが急かれますから
まああちこちちょっとちょっともう掃除機をかけてやりましたとやったかもしれませんだけど
それでも差があるんですね
その差は仁と慈の差なんです
で どういうことかというと
やっぱり自分がやってる仕事の世界だから
より明確というか より論理構成がより鮮明というかね
なんで国産が男で でも家でスープ料理作るのは女性ばっかしで
なんで女の人は国際にならないんですか？そんな仁と慈
仁と慈の差なんです で
女性は料理する場合はこの育てるという
人を育ててあげる ご飯食べさせてあげる
という基本的な働き 働きあるんですね
ですから 家で料理するのはなんとなく自然的に女性になってるんです
で 料理っていうのはもう人間食べるものであって
それはもう普通の一つの他の世の中にあるもう一つの行動と同じ
別に命に関係なく ただ食べる一つの行為だと
そういう考え 男の考え方なんですね
ですから 食事をする まな板みたいのこのそこは男性やっちゃうんです
で 女性はやりたくない
で 家に入ってきたら 家は別にもう食事作る工場ではなくて
命を預かってる場所ですから
そこで女性食べるんですね
になってるんですね 自然的に
その姿勢の中で 世の中どこでもそうなってるんです
この家庭システムが壊れたところで
今ヨーロッパでもだいたい交代でやったりとか
中国でもね そちら僕は人としての差が見えるんですけどね
論理で料理作ることと
またもう一つ違う違う方法でやるとか
いい例えじゃないんだけどね
料理の場合はね 例えあんまり良くないんだけどね
どうせ国際になっちゃったら
男性の料理もものすごい人外働いてますけどね
でもその時でも食べてもらいたいというか
まあ職業感じで お客さんを喜ばせてあげると
喜ばせてあげるために料理を作る
お母さんが喜ばせたくて料理を作ってるわけじゃないんです
もう食べたくない 食べなさい
という感じなんです ですから
国際にはちょっと向いてないんです
レストラン行ったらこれ食べなさい
でもあるでしょ？女の人々はレストランやってるところありますね
やっぱり厳しいんです
厳しいんだけど その分違う感じ
味があるんです ものすごく
味っていうのは まあなんとなく
ある日僕はあの仙川でこのセブンイレブンなんとか側にありましたからね
そこで弁当を買ったんですね
昼 で それもういっぱい人が並んで弁当買ってるんだから
その日はこのおばさん
このうちのこの店のおばあちゃんがレジで手伝って手伝ってるんですね
ですから 制服とか何もなくて
いっぱい人がいるんだから
で 若い人々はレジお金取ったりするんだけど
おばあちゃんがあの食べ物を持ってレンジに入れて温めてみんなにあげる
あれすごい感じが違うんですね
その時はもうお客さんに品物を売ってるんじゃなくて
はい どうぞという感じで
もう食べてくださいという感じなんですね
だから もう なるほど えらい違うんだと
決まってる弁当でもう決まってる秒単位でレンジで温めて
もう袋に入れて 全く決まってることやってるんだけど
やっぱりこの心の働きの差っていうのはすごい強烈に感じちゃう
まあ私は感じたんだけど
他の人も ですから僕は感じたと思いますけどね
超能力ないんだから 超能力あるならば
あれは超能力だからといってなんとか言えますけどね
で 他の人々だったら まあ品物ですから
まあもう温めてあげるだけで
向こう側が慣れているのは
やっぱり誰か育てたんですね
小さい時から大きくなるまで人を育てたんだから
もう食べなさいという感じなんですね
という風な この差があるでしょうね
女性がやってるレストランと男性がやってる小さな食堂
いろいろありますからね
どっかの大学の食堂があります
ずっとおばあちゃんがやっていて
みんなもう大学辞めても仕事をして
それからでも来たらすぐ行って
そこでご飯食べたりするっていうことはテレビで見てたんだけどね
やっぱり仕事だけだったら
学生が行く食堂にはもうまた二度とは行きたくないところなんですけど
やっぱりそこで仕事ではなくて
なんか違うものを食べていたんですね
ですから 後で社会人になっても
またあれ あのラーメン食べたいからってラーメン食べたりする
だからそういう風に この人の働きっていうものは
同じことをしたっても
ちょっと差が見えてくる
そこでアビダルマはまあ心理学的なものだから
で 私たちは何かものを見ると
こっちありますけど この人も
心もそれなりに働いています
だから結局言葉で説明はなかなかしにくいんだけど
確実にある働き 一つ人はヴィパッサナーはすごい基本的で
ヴィチャーラはもっとスモールして
すごい微妙で細かいということ
それはものすごい大げさに荒っぽく言えば考えること
合理的にいろいろめちゃくちゃ考えることなんですね
例えば